on the mound for the halos record of two
and two and a 5.40 era right-hander
jaime maria yani hernandez had an
excellent game last night
this one out to left field trying to get
down and it does that's a base hit
for hernandez and the rangers have that
lead man on the rangers have runners at
the corners with one out and d.j peters
coming up
peter is trying to go the other way and
he does so successfully drops out one in
for a hit fletcher had trouble picking
it up and the rangers played the first
run of the ball game a little bloop
single by dj peters there's nathaniel
lowe
bouncer up the middle diving stopped
nicely done by rangifo they can't get
the double play
but they do force out peters
for the second out of the inning dj
peters he's still out there at second
base he thinks he's safe oh look at dj
good call i thought he's a guy he's just
wishing he was safe that's good eyes so
great challenge rangers have the bases
loaded and nick solak at the plate
there's a ground ball it's hit to
rendifo second for one relay to first
that's a double play and the inning is
over
the angels had some opportunities in the
inning they turned that one aj alexey in
his second big league start lexi was
excellent his first time out and so a
good challenge to see if he can repeat
it and there's one away for ohtani with
the rangers leading one nothing alexis
2-2
and that's lifted out to left field
should be playable for martin
it is and they're two out now for the
angels will be jack mayfield and the
pitch he struck him out swinging on a
high fastball at 94. so it is a one two
three shutdown inning for aj alexey
jason martin now steps in with the
runner on nobody out announcing ball hit
over the head of the first baseman walsh
into right field pozo stops at second
base as lagarres comes up firing so for
the second inning in a row berea will
have to work with two men on and nobody
out the rangers have five hits already
in the ball game
up the middle we've been talking about
it could it be another six four three it
is that's absolutely huge second double
play of the game for berea
keeping that one down and that ground
ball rate this year for jaime is going
up it's a 43.9 percent up significantly
throughout his career used to be more of
a fly ball strikeout type pitcher two
outs runner at third top of the order
now yani hernandez
this one hit sharply and that one into
left field that's a base hit hernandez
delivers again as pozo touches home
plate and it's two nothing rangers the
mosquito really is kind of fun to watch
with the great contact we saw a weak
base hit in his first half-bat this one
he squares up lines it into
left center one hopper through the
infield batter is jared walsh there's a
little flare in the right center field
and that's going to find daylight and
drop in well that's what the rangers
have been doing to berea first and
second now nobody out in second inning
angel's trailing two nothing
and this one on the ground second base
could be two the flip to counter falefa
onto first double play four six three
and so the rangers
turn a double play of their own tonight
first and third two outs angels need a
two out hit from renjifo there's a high
pop up into short left field out goes
connor falefo with call now he gives way
to jason martin martin makes the catch
and the inning is over show hey otani
will be the next batter tony flew out to
left field his first time up and a swing
and a miss on what looked like a change
up that time from the right-hander and
one two three go the angels in the home
third tommy
retired five in a row
pop-up
i would suggest that bree get out of the
way and fletcher calls it two down so
jason martin steps in orange lutheran
one for one swing and a miss strike
three he does
korea starting to warm up aj alexey just
his second career start so far only one
hit allowed in this ball game two down
angel's looking for a spark can joe
adele provide it
and that's in there for a call third
strike fastball over the outer half
alexi again goes through the order one
two three he has now retired seven
straight eight in a row retired for
jaime berea gianni hernandez is two for
two
hits that one to renifo
finally gets hernandez out
two down nine in a row isaiah kind of
for lefa here's another ground ball
let's hit right to rent hifo near second
he fields and throws to first it's in
time to get kinder pelefa
so that will end the inning it's 10 in a
row eight in a row retired for alexi now
max stassi 2-2 and the swinging gonna
miss strike three stassi punches out two
gone slider we had seen around 81. this
one was at 79 miles an hour with a
little bit more depth renifo smashed on
one hump but to solac he drops to a knee
gets back up throws the first got him so
a very quick fifth inning for both
pitchers
both sides go one two three pj peters
will be the next batter hits that one
well
marsh going back on his horse makes the
catch two down that's 12 in a row great
grab that's a great route he took that
ball was scorched off the bat by peters
two outs berea looking to shut the door
let's make that
13 in a row
a baker's dozen
for jaime berea to the bottom of the
sixth inning juan legaris will lead
things off for the angels
there's the swing of this he strikes out
lugares good breaking ball here from aj
starting at the top of the strike zone
and finishing probably right at the
bottom going away five strikeouts now
for alexey 02
and the swing and a miss got him
swinging six strikeouts tonight brings
up shohei otani so alexi retired 12 in a
row at this point
got him looking
right on the outside corner a borderland
call goes alexis way he strikes out the
side in the sixth inning which will
undoubtedly be his last the first rookie
in the modern era to go five or more
innings and allow one or fewer hits in
each of his first two career stars
into the seventh inning mcsolacco for
two
swinging a miss got him talking about
tying up a hitter with a fastball up and
in two gone here at the top of the
seventh but now with the runner in
scoring position and brings up jose
trevino the 01. he's hit sharply over
third diving for it mayfield but he
can't get it it is a fair ball down the
line pozo around third scores standing
up trevino ends up at second with an rbi
double and the rangers lead three
nothing jose hit that one right over
third base
picks up his 23rd
rbi of the season first two are retired
the next two have gotten hits angels
have runners at the corners now tying
run will be coming to the plate and max
stassi is lifted out into right field
and garcia has to come in hard on this
one now he begins to slow and he makes
the catch in shallow right stassey the
final out in the bottom of the seventh
inning lagarus at third base shohei over
four with three strikeouts in
yesterday's game right now all for three
with two strikeouts in this game popped
up
on the left side of the infield
it is kinder fuller out in the short
left he takes it in
and uh patton gets out of the inning two
out knock for martin so we got first and
second that'll bring up jose trevino
this one on the ground that one is
through base hit low waved around third
base adele up with the baseball the
throw of the plate is high
that gets over stassi
and going into second base trevino he
makes it a four nothing rangers lead
rangers at double play depth arlo 02
and this one on the ground could be two
the flip to second one on the first in
time double play and that's a great way
to end it
a shutout tonight in los angeles the
rangers
split the series with a 4-0 win over the
angels
i